Where do I? I guess the-
Do you have slides?
Yes, I do.
Ask him to put up the slides.
We can put up the slides, please.
All right. Good afternoon, everybody, and welcome to this session.
My name is Juan Osorio. I'm from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center, and
I will be co-chairing this session with Dr.
Tomasz Gajewski from University of Chicago on
advances in therapeutic antibodies.
So before we jump into the...
Let me just...
There you go. Before we jump into these outstanding
presentations, I wanted to just take some time to introduce
of how we got here.
Especially because last year, we celebrated 50 years since the development of
the first monoclonal antibody. And I wanted to remind the audience
that the concept of using antibodies for therapy actually dates back
from the late 19th century,
when this person that is in this cartoon, Emil von Behring, along with
Kitasato, demonstrated that how using
serum from animals that were immunized with diphtheria or
tetanus could be used to both treat or prevent disease in other
animals. And in fact, at that time, these findings were quite
groundbreaking, and they were, for some people, actually considered as the pharmacy
of the future.
And around that concept, again, that was what served the basis of
the first Nobel Prize in Medicine in 1901 for these
two people.
And fast-forward to 1975 when
Kohler and Milstein developed the groundbreaking platform,
the hybridoma platform, for the development of monoclonal antibodies.
We have seen an exponential growth in the development of
therapeutic antibodies, and have been one of the most
transformative platforms for the treatment of a variety of
diseases. And something that is actually crucial to mention too
is that up to 50% of these compounds are actually used in
oncology,
with more to actually be approved.
Something that I think is also important to mention is that
this accelerated progress is grounded in
groundbreaking discoveries from many scientists that have
devoted their time to understand the mechanisms by which these
molecules actually engage different functions.
So therefore, really understanding these pathways are
crucial to further amplify the therapeutic
potential of these therapies.
So how do we move forward from here?
And how do we actually keep growing on the current
success that we have on antibodies?
So there are several emerging approaches that are currently quite
interesting. So from the antibody
discovery perspective, we're seeing how we're moving away from the traditional
trial-and-error empirical discovery of antibodies to actually
integrating AI and machine learning platforms to
accelerate the discovery and design of these molecules.
In addition, we are learning more about engineering approaches
to either amplify immune responses by engaging
additional co-stimulatory pathways, or in other contexts, actually
develop platforms such as masking engineering to prevent, to
bind a specific target in the periphery and therefore enhance the
therapeutic window of these approaches.
And then in terms of novel targets, we are expanding
the targeting repertoire from the traditional antigens that
are expressed on the surface,
to actually target some of those previously invisible
tumor-specific antigens that now have been described as the dark region of
the genome, or actually targeting the intracellular proteome via
peptide-HLA complexes.
Lastly, we're learning also that some of these conformational
epitopes are only accessible in living cells and are also providing
novel platforms to target these pathways.
And lastly,
we are harnessing some tumor-penetrating pathways to
essentially amplify
antigen presentation by tumor cells.
So what I'm showing here is just a little bit of a taste of some of the
fantastic talks that we'll be hearing today.
And with that, I will proceed with the presenters. Thank you so much.
So,
let me see.
Yeah.
So the first one is Ryan Herency from Discovery Medicine.
All right.
Excellent. So thanks very much to the organizers and to you all
for coming to this talk today. It's a pleasure to share
this story of BIGHAT and BIGHAT-299 as a first-in-class
CCAM6-directed TCE for diverse solid
malignancies.If
we can--
There we go.
Before we dive into the biology, just wanted to orient this organization to a very
brief overview of Big Hat. We're an ML native biotechnology company
based up in the Bay Area that uses generative tools to
discover and optimize antibody therapeutics for patients.
Over the last six and a half years, we've built and integrated two core
technologies, generative AI ML tools for discovering and
optimizing antibodies, which needs a lot less introduction in
2026 than it did in 2019 when we started this company,
and synthetic biology tools. And sort of what that means
is--
I don't know how to
advance this here.
There's a clicker.
There's a clicker? This guy? There we go.
What that means is a set of ribosomal extracts or cell-free expression technologies
that allow us to rapidly build, recombinantly purify, and
characterize antibodies from diverse fragments of various chains to then
complex multi-specifics very quickly to then generate the training data required
to power high-performant ML models that are sensitive to specific
variations in the antibody sequence.
And so this lab in the loop allows us to characterize not just antibody binding
properties across relevant preclinical orthologs, but also functional
attributes, cytokine release, TDCC activity as we'll look at today, but
also biophysical attributes, stability, solubility, hydrophobicity,
self-association, and immunogenicity risk.
And so we deploy these technologies in collaboration with large
pharma partners, many of whom are represented here today, to advance their
pipelines, but also to build a deep portfolio of
next-generation cancer assets. A combination of ADCs, which will
be presented by my colleague Anthony Cadena on Wednesday.
Big Hat-810 rapidly progressing towards patients this summer, and
Big Hat-299, which we'll talk about right now.
So 299 is, as I mentioned, a first-in-class CCAM6-directed TCE
that is conditionally active on the basis of the expression of CCAM6 between
normal and malignant cells. Now, CCAM6 is one of these
classic solid tumor targets. It's highly overexpressed in diverse epithelial
origin malignancies of colon and lung, but also pancreatic and gastric
origin. But it's also expressed meaningfully in solid normal tissues of
those same organic sources. But the problem that's derailed a number of
prior attempts to drug this target is expression in the myeloid tree.
And so there are a variety of assets that have been advanced into clinic or
preclinical studies and published on CCAM6 over the last 20
years that have ended in poor PK and poor
bioavailability peripherally and substantial on-target cytopenias that are
dose-limiting because of an overwhelming peripheral antigen sink,
particularly on mature neutrophils.
And so Genentech has a DM1 CCAM6
ADC that was published in the late 2000s, and Bayer had tinirelimab
advanced into phase one in the mid-2010s that all sort of met the same
fate.
This is also true of a variety of other assets that all feature the same sort of
common design principles of high-affinity binding to CCAM6,
leading to limited clinical benefit and substantial on-target toxicity.
And so taking this biology into account, CCAM6 is a perfect
target for a platform like Big Hat's.
We're able to learn from these clinical failures and deeply interrogate the biology
of the target throughout the body to determine what is the single
highest expressing cell population and what is the
antigen density at a protein level on that cell population.
And making sure across solid tissues, as well as the blood and hematopoietic
system, that we can pin that down very carefully and precisely across a range of
human donors, and also importantly, characterizing that in preclinical species.
And so we see that that cell population that we need to be very cognizant of and
include in our iterative modeling are mature neutrophils with about 28,000 to
30,000 copies per cell. A very meaningful expression of CCAM6
that's regulated as myelopoiesis happens.
But when we take primary biopsies from patients with cancers of colon and lung
adenocarcinoma origin, again, pancreatic and gastric cancer, we see that
CCAM6 is very broadly expressed within the context of a single
patient. So the relative array of different antigen
densities is narrow. It's highly expressed and constitutively expressed in
cancer cells at the tune of hundreds of thousands or millions of copies per cell,
setting up one to two log difference between the highest expressing critical normal
tissue and the lowest expressing cells in the
cancer. And across patients, again, this is sort of homogeneous.
Every one of these bar chart lines on the left is an individual tumor core with
the relative fraction of the cells in that particular biopsy
that express a certain IHC level, and the IHC assay's been cross-correlated with
the antigen-binding assays by flow.
So IHC 2+ corresponds to about 150,000 copies per cell.
And so this biology describes the problems that we've seen clinically
for these types of assets in the past and sets up an optimization problem.
Can we build a T-cell engager that is environmentally aware,
that doesn't have activity against neutrophils with that 30,000 copies per cell,
and robustly depletes cancer cells with hundreds of thousands or millions of copies
per cell? And so within that design build test loop powered by the
platform, we're testing every single antibody design against primary
neutrophils and cancer cells with a relevant E to T ratio,
optimizing the geometry, the affinity, the
linkers, and the relative positioning of those binders in a T-cell
engager to differentially kill and maximize the delta
IC50 between these cell populations.
And so where we arrive is a CCAM6 binder, a fully human VHH
with an extremely weak affinity, a three micromolar KD, an
extremely fast off rate that doesn't bind to neutrophils, so
that's the middle panel on the top, and has a K avidity of
about 11 nanomolar
when both arms are engaged in an EC50 of about one nanomolar against cancer
cells.CD3 is 200 nanomolar. CD3 is about
optimal for this system that maximizes cytotoxicity against cancer cells,
preserves low cytokine release, and reduces activity in the periphery.
And it's a pH conditional CD3 that has about a 20-fold tighter Kd in the
acidic condition. If the tumor happens to be acidic, then
the activity ramps up to accommodate for that and target lower
expressing cell populations in the TME, which could not only be cancer cells, but
possibly myeloid suppressing cells in the tumor bed as well.
But all the studies that you'll see in the forthcoming slides are done at pH 7.4.
And so the primary mechanism of action and mechanism of safety of this asset is
contingent upon the differences in the expression level in the cells that we're
looking at in that particular experiment, and is not performed with diverse
pHs of the assay medium itself.
And so what we see is benchmarking against a conventional high affinity TCE, which
kills cell populations equivalently regardless of target density, that
BIGHAT-299's potency scales with the target density on the cell
population. And so then you would ask, if you have precise control over where
that delta IC50 and the breakpoint lies, how do we rationally select that
to avoid escape from lower density target expression?
And so again, using the distribution of CCAM6 that we see in
cancer patient biopsies and primary tissues, we can see that across a
population of biopsies, there are very few to no cells that express less than
80,000 copies per cell. And so that's where we rationally put the breakpoint for
this particular asset. And we see about 1,000-fold difference in the IC50s
between cells above and below that particular cut point.
Being a small biotech, we bring a phlebotomist into BIGHAT HQ.
My lab mates very kindly offer up their blood and veins, and we put the
TCE directly in ex vivo. And we can look for the toxicity of the TCE
in a fully autologous system between monocytes, macrophages, and neutrophils.
And again, in contrast to a high affinity TCE that destroys these populations
equivalently,
BIGHAT-299 has no activity against monocytes and macrophages, which
have about three to 10,000 copies per cell.
And then the IC50s against neutrophils are around 20
to 100 plus nanomolar consistently across donors, setting up about
1,000 to 10,000-fold differential in the IC50s between our
cancer populations that have a one to 10
picomolar IC50 and our neutrophils.
Cytokine release tracks very nicely with target engagement, so we see low and
heavily right-shifted EC50s for
cytokine release ex vivo in whole blood versus a high affinity TCE.
And then in preclinical models of CCAM6 malignancies across a variety of
different biologies, we're seeing complete responses around 50 micrograms per
kilogram once weekly and meaningful anti-tumor activity versus an isotype
even at 20 micrograms per kilogram on a once weekly basis.
This is in models of lung adeno and squamous carcinomas, colon
cancer of adenocarcinoma origin, and pancreatic malignancies as well.
And with our partners at Champions Oncology, we conducted a mini clinical trial of
PDXs, so 12 or 15 different models, again, across a range of different
treatment paradigms and different histologies and different target expression
profiles. And firstly, see that the mechanism of action in vitro translates very
nicely in vivo, where activity is dependent on target expression,
and looking in particular at a diversity of different histologies.
And so the model on the far left is a MSS low colon
mass taken from a liver met. We also see EGFR wild type lung
adenocarcinomas that respond very nicely as well.
But the key question is, can you achieve activity at a pharmacologically
relevant and safe exposure? So, there's lots of programs that can show activity if
we dose up in mice and put together a semi-contrived system,
because murine models of cancer are only so good.
Firstly, evaluating toxicity, there is no ortholog for CCAM6 in the rodent genome.
So CCAM6 seems to have split genomically from a paralog after
primate and
humans have split from the rodent common ancestor.
And so we create a humanized mouse model of CCAM6 that is a
CD34 engrafted animal that's genomically humanized for a variety of
myeloid promoting factors in the marrow context.
And so we can see over 16 weeks, a relatively competent lymphoid
compartment that emerges, but also a myeloid compartment that
expresses human CCAM6 with the relevant cell surface markers denoting
neutrophils. And the high affinity TCE recapitulates the human
tox phenotype exquisitely with a single dose, reducing monocytes,
neutrophils, and macrophages to zero.
Animals have an impressively negative clinical course and
can't generally tolerate a second dose with substantial body weight loss.
But BIGHAT-299 has no detectable effect on these cells in excess of two mgs per kg
on a once weekly basis.
The same asset then in primates, the first thing that we see in terms of
the PK is very different from what's come before, where the
half-life is not 24 hours with poor bioavailability
from that major peripheral sink from the neutrophils.
We see dose proportionality, and we see a multi-day clearance profile consistent
with a monoclonal antibody.
We've developed a sub-Q route of administration, so the antibody's
soluble in excess of 120 mgs per mil,
which we think is not only important for mitigating the Cmax as it applies to
CRS, but reducing the peripheral exposure to high concentrations that could
drive unwanted on-target tox, given that the periphery is our key target tissue.
And we see good bioavailability from the sub-Q route and low peripheral cytokine
release in the first cycle. And then the cell counts are normal despite two
to three doses, so three sequential doses in the study, whereas the Genentech
ADC takes neutrophils to zero and the animals come down.
Histologically, there's no evidence of immune cell infiltration or any on-target
action in solid organic tissues that express CCAM6.
And so integrating all of this data, the preclinical CDX and the
PDX, the ex vivo studies in human neutrophils and the primate
data, we can compile a QSP model of predicted
activity in humans and see meaningful pharmacologic activity
predicted across lung adenocarcinomas and CRC
around flat dose exposures of 100 micrograms once weekly.
And even when we're advancing towards multiple milligrams per
week on a, again, flat dose and sub-Q paradigm, seeing safety
margins
ranging from about tenfold to 200-fold as those exposures
increase. And so even as we get towards three to 10 mgs once weekly, still having
meaningful cushion before we begin to touch the neutrophil population.So,
big picture here, I guess I'd
love to have convinced you in the last 12 minutes that
299 represents a credible first-in-class opportunity on CCAM6,
optimized multi-parametrically across develop-ability attributes,
functional attributes with the relevant sort of preclinical cell
populations that have been described by the clinical history on this target
previously. That offers a very meaningful sort of opportunity for patients,
particularly given that this drug molecule has the opportunity to treat 10% to
20% of all new cancer diagnoses annually based on the target expression profile.
And so, we're very sort of proudly proceeding quickly towards the clinic.
And so IND is expected in the second half of this year and
first-in-human dose escalation in patients with colorectal cancers and lung
adenocarcinomas. And so just a call to arms for those who are
providers in this space who have interest in this type of program, we'd love to
meet with you and discuss this asset and opportunities to bring your patients into
our study. And also partners who have interest in this program or
technologies like it, we'd love to continue that conversation as well.
So just thank you very much for your attention.
Again, to the organizers for having me today and of course to the broader Big Hat
family for making this drug possible. Thank you.
Thanks for that very complete presentation.
We've got a minute and a half for questions.
Yeah. Thanks for the great talk. So you still have like a 10
nanometer 220 affinity of
CD3 at the pH 7.4.
So are you still some sort of release?
So what's the mechanism that you saw then almost very, very low
tox?
How you define the CD3 affinity?
Yeah.
The threshold for your antibody.
Yeah. So the CD3 affinity is again, just empirically optimized within the context
of the T cell engager scaffold as we're measuring the IC50 of high and low
affinity CD3 constructs against neutrophils and primary cancer cells.
And so, the CD3 KD of about 200 nanometer at pH 7.4
is arrived at just simply by co-optimizing the geometry and the relative valency
of the two CCAM6 binders alongside the CD3 binder,
trying to maximize delta IC50.
Thank you.
Okay, thanks. We're going to have to move on to keep everything on time.
Sorry about that. So thanks very much for a great opening presentation.
Okay, so we're going to move on to the next presentation,
ENA-101, our first-in-class bispecific T-cell engager
targeting a DART fox peptide presented by solid tumors by Jason
Dukes.
Thank you very much. Thank you to the organizers for selecting our abstract for an
oral presentation. It's a real privilege to be here and present our first-in-class
bispecific targeting a DART antigen called DART fox.
It's also a privilege to be able to come early and get exposed to some German death
metal as you wait. So that was fun.
I got to figure out how to advance this.
Clicker.
Okay. Here's my disclosures.
So, I think you're all here and accepting that advances in therapeutic antibodies
have transformed the treatment in oncology, especially
T-cell engagers. Engaging the potent T cell really is starting to
transform solid tumor therapy. However, at NAR, we believe there's two challenges,
or there's a number of challenges, but we're trying to crack two challenges that
remain. One challenge is cancer-specific targets that are
shared among patient populations.
And to address that challenge, we've
built our EDAP platform, which is a platform for discovery and
validation of novel antigens derived from the previously thought to be
non-protein coding regions of the genome.
And then the second challenge is, it's not a menial task to generate a T cell
engager that really effectively engages T cells and
recapitulates their immune cell biology.
And so we strongly believe in optimizing
T cell engager molecules together to give drug-like properties that you want, such
as half-life extension, but suitable for a particular binder and for a particular
target. And typically, cancer-specific targets tend to be lower
copy number on the cell surface. And so it's really important that we
effectively engineer these molecules to maximize engaging T
cells and redirecting their activity appropriately.
And so that's where our ENTICE platform has come in.
And ENA-101 is the product of both these platforms.
So at SITC last year, we unveiled our discovery and validation
of this novel target called DART fox. Why is it called DART fox?
Well, it's an alternative open reading frame that sits out of frame in the
canonical gene FOXM1. FOXM1 is a
proto-oncogene that's involved in all the hallmarks of cancer from initiation,
progression, metastasis, cancer stemness.
Really, cancer cells cannot grow and proliferate in the absence of
FOXM1. So it really is a critical gene.
It's a transcription factor that's very difficult to therapeutically target for a
number of reasons. DART fox offers a unique opportunity as a
completely out-of-frame alternative open reading frame.
It has cancer selectivity in its translation, and DART
fox yields a short polypeptide, a
little bit less than 100 amino acids in length.
And from this, a cell process and presents several class I HLA peptides
from DART fox open reading frame. One of these, which we call DART fox A3,
is very robustly presented on HLA-A3.
And so this is the target that we're pursuing with ENA-101.
As you can see at the bottom of this panel,
this target DART fox is truly a pan-cancer target, and it has broad
expression across major cancer types in solid tumors whilst
retaining a relatively clean profile in healthy tissues.
So being able to target DART fox offers a really unique and compelling
opportunity for potentially transforming patient care in solid
tumors.
And so we partnered with Aloy Therapeutics to identify TCR mimics or
TCR mimetics, whichever you prefer to say.
We identified high-affinity antibodies that bound specifically to DART
fox A3 presented by HLA-A3, but not to off targets.
We reformatted these after affinity maturation to achieve very high-affinity
molecules and incorporated this into our ENTICE platform, which
consists of a clinically validated intermediate affinity anti-CD3
scFv on a backbone of a science FC domain to
deliver half-life extension.So
ENA-101 has drug-like properties. That's really important.
It's not just good enough to have a molecule that works, but you need to be able to
make it and make it effectively. So it has the properties that we want in terms of
kinetic engagement, very high affinity, double-digit picomolar
binding to the peptide HLA molecule whilst retaining high
specificity. We can make this with high yields and purity in a contemporary
mammalian expression system, and the molecules are highly stable
and really deliver good drug-like properties.
So how does it function? Well, here we have a select number of cancer cell
lines that represent the levels of antigen that we see in primary tumors.
So we've done a lot of primary tumor mass spectrometry as well as cell and mass
spectrometry, a lot of RNA expression analyses to ensure that the
models that we're using to understand the activity of
ENA-101 represent what we see in primary tissue.
And so a couple of cell lines here where we do
sensitive co-culture assays with primary human T cells, titrating amounts of our
drug. You can see there on the left, and then in the table on the right, very
potent activation of T cells. We've also developed a
control cell line, which is our colorectal cell line that we have knocked
out using CRISPR editing the peptide region from DART FOX that we're
targeting along with flanking residues.
This is important really to establish the specificity of the binder in
ENA-101 and the specificity of the molecule.
And you can see there on the left, we see no activity against this knockout
version, and we confirm by mass spectrometry that we cannot detect
the DART FOXA3 peptide in that cell line.
And this T cell activation leads to potent killing. So we see killing.
This is using the Incucyte platform and performed on a number of cells, just
representing again a cell line that endogenously express
HLA-A03 and DART FOX. We see killing down to and including 10
picomolar maximal killing with EC50 sub 10 picomolar.
So a very potent and specific molecule.
Peptide HLA targets, as many of you know, are human specific.
Standard tox species are not relevant as they do not have the
target of interest, and so we have to establish preclinical safety
using bespoke methods for generating that
data. The precedented way that most companies are pursuing this is
to use sensitive T cell activation readouts in
co-culture, where we take cells that represent major
healthy tissue types, so primary human cultured
normal cells, co-culture these with our drug and primary T cells,
and look for T cell activation. And so here on the left, we see
representative cells from major tissue types, and at the bottom, we've listed out
all the cell types to date that we've exhaustively de-risked
ENA-101 against, and we see no activity against any of these cell
types, but robust activity against our cancer cell
lines that represent DART FOX. So really a highly specific
and selective profile, also highlighting the selectivity
of DART FOX as a target.
To speak more to that point about selectivity of DART FOX and the risk of
potential on-target, off-tumor effects, we know that the expression
of FOXM1 outside of tumors is the highest in CD34 positive bone marrow
cells, and so we've chosen to specifically focus on these and
de-risk those. You can see in this middle graph that we've tested HLA
relevant CD34 positive bone marrow cells in these assays, and we see no
activity of our agent against this, again
supporting DART FOX tumor selectivity and the
specificity of ENA-101.
We've also have in-house phlebotomists like the former speaker.
We also have very willing donors,
both in-house and in the community.
So we perform ex vivo
whole blood assays to establish CRS.
We don't see any evidence of increased risk of CRS with ENA-101,
and we've also performed these motif analyses.
These are key specificity assays that form part of an
IND-enabling study, really to try to predict potential
off-target peptides that might exist.
This involves taking the wild type peptide sequence, mutating each
of the amino acids to all the other amino acids, the
19 naturally occurring ones, and then asking the question, which of those
peptides does our binder care about?
And that can define a motif that you can then search against the human proteome.
And in doing that, we see a very specific profile with ENA-101, and
we've identified no risk peptides to date with that approach.
We also see compelling in vivo efficacy, so obviously moving from a static
dish to a sort of a more closely representative of what the clinical
situation would be. Agree with the former speaker that these are rather contrived
models. Nonetheless, I think it's important to move away from the dish and
establish in vivo efficacy. So here we're using cell line
derived models as xenografts. We take NSG mice in
these first experiments where we're implanting with our cell line
that expresses DART FOX antigen. We allow that to grow for seven days to measurable
size, and then we're implanting human PBMCs and then treating once
weekly with ENA-101. And you can see here doses
down to 50 micrograms per kg up to one mg per kg.
We're not seeing yet a dose effect.
This was our first study in this model, so we seek to expand this study and push
the dose even further. But really after four weekly doses of
ENA-101, we have complete regression of tumors in these mouse models.
So this really speaks to the high potency of
ENA-101.
We also see, as we would hope with inclusion of FC, a sort of
PK profile in vivo in mice that we would want for a half-life extended molecule.
We think this is really critical to have half-life extension to maximize
durability of response and overall response rates in patients.
And so it's nice to see that at least in mice, we're seeing greater than two-week
half-life as we'd expect. We're due to repeat this data
ongoing with mice that are transgenic for human FCRN
for a more closely predictive PK profile, but ultimately
we'll be determining this in humans.And then
finally, just to close off the presentation, a little bit about what's
next in terms of the clinic. So we presented some similar data to this
at SITC, but just to come back to the expression of DARF-fox and the
opportunity. I said earlier that it is a pan-cancer target.
So here we're using RNA in situ hybridization to understand
prevalence in terms of how many tumors are positive for our
antigen, but also get at the question of homogeneity.
We think a good level of homogeneity with a clean target is really important.
So we've now assessed close to 600 tumor samples in-house using this technique,
and then what you can see here is a couple of things.
One is that pretty much all tumors express a very high level
of DARF-fox. We see all tumors are positive.
But importantly, if you really focus on those tumor types that have exceptional
expression of DARF-fox, so at a medium to high level, at a cutoff
of score of two by RNA-ISH, a couple of the tumors really stand out.
So lung squamous, triple-negative breast, head and neck, et cetera, all upwards of
70% of the samples express a score of DARF-fox of two or
greater.
This gives us a unique opportunity with peptide HLA targeted therapies to
move forward with a first-in-human study where we'll be able to include a couple of
these tumor types where we only really pre-screen for HLA and have all
comers in these tumor types. And this has some significant advantages
as we move forward in development, but also the opportunity to move more broadly
across many different solid tumor types of high unmet need.
So in summary, our EDAPT and ENTISE platforms have been leveraged to both
identify and validate a novel and exciting target that we've called
DARF-fox. We believe this is a really promising target, has all the hallmarks
of a target that you'd want to pursue with sensitive T cell engager
type molecules. It's homogeneous in expression, it's highly prevalent, it's shared
among patients, it's cancer specific.
And then we've used our ENTISE platform to develop the ENA 101 T cell engager to
target this peptide presented on HLA A3.
And ENA 101 really has all the hallmarks of a best in class, as well as
a first in class bispecific
T cell engager for solid tumors. So very robustly made, high affinity
for tumor target whilst retaining selectivity, very potent, efficacious in vivo
models, strong killing.
And as I said earlier, the evidence of the DARF-fox
expression in major solid tumors gives us routes towards recruiting all comers
in an HLA A3 positive setting.
So we're currently in GMP and IND enabling preclinical studies.
These are ongoing, much like the former talk.
We're due to enter the clinic with regulatory submission later this
year. And thank you for your attention.
I'd like to thank also everyone at Nara Bio.
We've got a very talented team of colleagues there that have really
made this possible, and we're all excited about being able to take this molecule
into the clinic and hopefully offer significant benefit to patients.
Thank you for your attention.
Thanks so much for that presentation.
We have two minutes for questions,
and I'm
ready to start if there are no takers.
First of all,
what's the prevalence of HLA A3 in the general population?
Yes, good question. So in the US, it's between 20% and 25%,
in the EU, between 25% and 30%. So it's one of the best
outside of HLA too.
And then I'm curious,
your antibody that recognizes the peptide MHC complex, can you use that to
stain cells-
Yes
... so you can actually see the epitope presented by HLA
A3 and not just one and the other?
Yes, a very good question. So I think it depends on the technique.
So we have been doing some work to stain live cells.
I think the challenge is moving outside of the live or maybe
flash frozen setting into a traditional IHC setting where you have
FFP material. You typically get destruction of the peptide HLA
architecture, and so it becomes very difficult to detect.
Also, peptide HLAs, as I'm sure you know, tend to trend towards the lower density
end.
DARF-fox A3 is very robustly presented, we believe, and have evidence that it's
expressed in the hundreds to low thousands of copies per cell.
But I think these limitations with peptide HLA and FFP material
limit us from using that in that sort of preserved material.
But certainly in the live cell setting, that's something that we're doing a bit
more of.
Yeah. You must have thought about tumor heterogeneity
of both components.
Yes.
Right?
Lower HLA A3 and-
Yeah, exactly. And I think that's why-
Beta-two M loss and-
Yeah. So loss of heterozygosity is always going to be a challenge that we won't be
able to fully overcome with the targeted therapy.
I think the data sets that come from thousands of patients now suggest
that's around about 7% to 10% for A3, so it's
not major.
In terms of HLA down regulation, which is more common in later stage
disease, I think that's why you need to drive the affinity of your binder to this
very high affinity. So we've pushed this to double digit picomolar affinity
so that we can really capture a wide variety of peptide
levels.
I think we have another questioner.
Wouldn't you think that you simply select for cells
that don't express DARF-fox by taking the antibody that
kills off all the cells that do have it?
Sorry, I missed the question. Could you repeat it, please?
Oh, I mean, wouldn't you select for cells that don't
express DARF-fox or express it at a very low level with
your therapy?
Yeah, I think that's-
Along the lines of the question before.
Yeah, that's a common challenge with anything.
Unless 100% of the cells express it, you have that challenge.
I think there's a lot of data that speak to bystander effect, epitope spreading,
where you need sort of a minimum of 25% of a population to be positive
if you're flipping the immune system.
I think also when you think about the biology of FOXM1, as I said earlier, the
cells can't divide and grow within the absence of FOXM1,
largely in our experience and from the literature.
And so I think when we look at those snapshots in time of the expression of our
target, we know that that can change throughout time.
So again, I think targeting something that the cells care about really
plays in our favor here.
But they can't afford to lose it, the FOXM1.
Yes. And FOXM1 coding sequence contains the alternative open reading frame of
DARF-fox.So where you have the fox in one sequence
and you have the translational machinery that will translate dark fox open
reading frame, you'll get dark fox.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. Thanks so much. I think we'll move on to stay on time, if that's okay.
All right. Thank you.
All right, so our third presentation, NRP1 Drives a
Novel Cross-Presentation Pathway Exploitable by Peptide-Linked Antibodies
to Redirect Viral Memory T Cells Against Solid Tumors, by
Dr. Jeffrey Multhaup from MD Anderson.
Thank you. Thanks to everybody for being here today, and thank you for
the chairs of this session for selecting us to be an oral presentation.
I'm
presenting this on behalf of my laboratory, but Anne
Phillips did really lead this project, but she couldn't be
here today because of family issues.
Let's see.
The clicker.
Yeah.
Clicker?
I'm a'clicking.
No, no, the clicker, not the mouse.
Oh, gosh. That's my backup. Okay.
Yeah. So, just wanted to show the...
Okay. So we got interested in neuropilin sort of by
serendipity a number of years ago when we showed that neutrophil elastase,
which is elaborated by granulocytes in tumor
microenvironment in particular, can be taken up by
cells
and by cancer cells. So this is a 231 cells.
This is all published. I'm going to go very fast through this, but it highlights
the pathway that we recapitulate with an antibody. So let me go through this.
That if you co-incubate neutrophil elastase with the
tumor cell, they'll take it up. They take it up rapidly.
You can see it internalized. It actually goes to an
endosomal compartment within the first 10 minutes, then traffics to the lysosome,
shown here by confocal imaging, where you can stain both NE and the
LAMP2, a component of the lysosome.
We then did cross-linking
immunoprecipitation with antibody to NE, immunoprecipitation and mass spec,
and found that NE was actually binding to neuropilin.
Neuropilin peptide showed up in the mass spec, and then when we used cells that
expressed it, it would bind, and those that didn't, it didn't, and knockout and
knockin experiments.
And then we showed that actually NE traffics along with NRP1 to that
same space. We mapped the binding domain, which was a
CN rule peptide binding domain, so very common for
this molecule,
and that's shown in blue. We showed that the affinity of
elastase to the target was around 38 nanomolar.
And we showed further that a peptide derived from neutrophil elastase called
PR1, which is an HLA-A2 restricted peptide, could be
processed out of an elastase once it's trafficked
into those compartments and then put on the cell
surface on HLA-A2. And
we've also developed an antibody to that PR1-HLA-A2 that was the
very first TCR mimic that made it into the clinic, and now we're in a
multi-center trial with that. And I'm not going to explain that one.
But we did find PR1-HLA-A2 on breast cancer as well.
So this is patient-derived material, again, showing on confocal
imaging that actually PR1-A2, which we use the antibody for, can
be
visualized on the surface of those cells.
So what about NRP1? Neuropilin is
commonly involved in axonal nerve growth
early on in embryogenesis. The knockout is lethal embryologically.
But in adult tissues, it's also expressed on some T
cells, myeloid cells, particularly dendritic cells, and out of those subsets,
particularly plasmacytoid DCs.
It's also on astrocytes.
And it is involved in many things. So there's a couple of binding
domains. One is the A1A2, which is a semaphorin binding domain, and a
B1B2, which binds VEGF.
So NRP1 acts as a co-receptor for VEGF
on endothelial cells.
But it's broadly expressed and highly expressed on the cell surface of many
cancers. This just shows the RNA expression from TCGA.
So based on this and based on our early evidence that NE can get
cross-presented, we thought, "Well, what if we built an antibody to NRP1
targeting a similar epitope or motif?
Could we drive
internalization and then efficient cross-presentation?" Something very hard to
do traditionally in solid tumors since they're not really thought to be doing this.
And then in sufficient numbers so that they could be visualized
by circulating T cells that we all have.
Say, if you attached a viral peptide onto that antibody, could it be
cross-presented and recognized by circulating
viral specific T cells? That was the premise.
We went through an antibody campaign.
I'm not going to talk about all of these, but we ended with
one select candidate that binned in the same
binding domain as our NE.
We called that 5D6. We humanized that, and
then the 5D6 will bind to NRP1, so that's shown here
in A. I guess I can't get that to work.
But anyway, so it's shown in panel A.
This is by ELISA, so it binds quite high affinity by Octet, so
bioluminescent interferometry with a KD of two
nanomolar.
We showed by an ELISA where you can displace with VEGF.
You get partial displacement, so it
binds close to that same B1B2 domain that NE did.
And it shows cross-reactivity to both human and mouse.
That was important for clinical development.
So it does bind CD11c cells as well on
mice.And we made two flavors of this antibody.
One was with a chemical linkage
of peptide onto the antibody, and the second one was recombinant.
So we used a standard pH sensitive protease cleavable linker
and attached then the peptide. So we also mutated the
S239 so that we could get a good
conjugation with this linker and
measured how much CMV NLV peptide.
We also used CG1 peptide, which is a protein or peptide derived from
cathepsin G, a leader sequence. You'll hear more about that
later from a
few presentations on from Crossbow where we developed an
antibody against CG1A2. And so we wanted
to then test to see whether or not this would also get cross presented.
We did the same thing with a recombinant with NLV, this PP65
CMV immunodominant HLA-A2 restricted peptide.
And then we cloned out TCRs from patients who
were immune
to CMV and then constructed by knocking that
TCR into the TRAC locus of polyclonal T cells.
We constructed TCR T cells to use as our readouts to see whether or not
peptides were cross presented.
So first things first, 5D6, it binds.
So you can see on the far left, it binds to cells that express NRP1.
When we knock NRP1 out, it doesn't.
And
so this is true in triple negative breast cancer,
non-small cell lung carcinoma, renal cell carcinoma.
And it localizes, so here's a confocal imaging experiment
where 5D6
binds to NRP1 and is colocalized into an endosome very quickly and
then into a lysosomal compartment very similar to NE.
We demonstrated not only cross presentation, so it was enough NLV
peptide on the cell surface be recognized by these TCRTs, which then secreted
TNF alpha and gamma interferon in a dose dependent way,
both including breast cancer, lung cancer, and
renal cell carcinoma cell lines. And that it was TAP1 dependent, at least
partially, because if we knock down TAP1 by
siRNA, we could show that
there was reduced recognition of the peptide on the cell surface.
So it could recognize them, but could it kill?
And so these are experiments now, cytotoxicity using the same
TCRT against NLV, the CMV peptide.
When we paint the cells with the antibody that's linked to the NLV,
we get good killing of those targets.
This is effector target ratio is down at as low as two and a half to
one,
and we can see not only potent killing with NLV peptide, but we see
it with also CG1 peptide. And this is using T cells specific for the
CG1 HLA-A2.
The TCL recognition of that NLV peptide, CMV, is dose dependent.
So the more antibody you have, at least with the recombinant
form of the antibody, the better killing you get.
With the chemical conjugation, we're almost sort of saturated even down at 0.25
micromolar of the antibody. So we can deliver enough peptide on the cell
surface to be
recognized by T cells.
The CG1, which we enumerated by mass spec, we can see 200 copies of
that on the cell surface.
So enough to get recognized by T cells.
So then we asked whether or not those T cells would have any activity in a
preclinical model. So we'd been introduced to NSGs.
And so these are the nod scid gamma
knockout. And you can see that this is the experimental approach.
We put the tumor in,
and then 24 hours later, we come in with the antibody, either isotype or
with
non-peptide linked or with the
peptide linked antibody. And then the second day, we come in with
TCRT, so a single dose of the TCRT, and then do
bioluminescence.
So you can see that in far left with MB231 cells, we implant
those cells
within days. On the same day, you can see them, they get caught up in the lung
because we do tail vein injections as a kind of a
quasi metastatic model.
And without the T cells, without the antibody, you get growth of
those
tumors. But on day seven, they're eliminated by the T cells after exposure to
the
antibody. That's a dose dependent phenomenon.
These are sort of out of order, unfortunately, between the left and the middle
panel. But you can see that at one times 10 and six, so a
million T cells, that wasn't enough, but at 5 million T cells, we could
destroy the tumor, and at 10 million, you get a full elimination.
And then at
H2023, the non-small cell lung carcinoma, similarly, we see
activity at 10 million cells.
So then we wanted to know whether or not there was any evidence for
toxicity here. So because NRP1 is expressed on normal
tissues, we know it's on HUVEC, so
endothelial cells, venous endothelial cells.
And we can see here that those cells after
being treated with the antibody, the peptide linked antibody, and then exposed to
the TCRT, there was no killing
and no recognition. So here's the gamma interferon and TNF alpha
secretion. So the T cells couldn't see it in sufficient quantity to be
recognized. The NRP1 on white blood cells in
the mouse, so these are granulocytes and CD11c positive cells.
There's no change in those circulating cells after exposure to both the
antibody and the TCRT, meaning that there was no
activity against those cells, even though they expressed
NRP1.
And in the mouse model here, this is an HLA-A2
transgenic, so this is the O201 allele homozygous
with a human beta 2m knockin,
so that you get broad HLA-A2 expression on all tissues in the animal.
In this case, even exposure to the antibody and
TCRT, we don't see any toxicity in any of the vital
tissues, including brain, which
expresses NRP1. Now, we don't think the antibody gets across the blood brain
barrier, so we're doing additional experiments there to actually confirm there's no
toxicity.So, in summary,
we showed that a peptide linked to NRP1 antibody, in this case 5D6,
mediates cross-presentation sufficient enough on tumor
cells to be recognized by T cells and killed by those T cells in a viral
specific peptide way. We don't see that same
killing in NRP1 expressing healthy cells, meaning the
granulocytes, endothelial cells, so both human and mouse.
And so we think that this is a way that may be
able to be pushed forward as a therapeutic where we get cross
presentation of viral peptides in a tumor, and
thereby could be sensitive to circulating viral specific T cells
in the host.
I have to say that this is not our idea.
This is not a novel idea. Ralph Steinman originally pursued this
with DEC-205,
and there it was a problem of DEC-205 being on
tumor cells, but it's certainly on dendritic cells.
NRP1 here is also on dendritic cells, but we don't know whether it affects
cross-priming as of yet. Those experiments are yet to be done.
So I'd like to thank the people who really did this work, including a few
people here in the audience. Scott Shih from Orbit at MD
Anderson, who's helped us a lot with some of the antibody
development. And people in my laboratory, and in
the Eclipse platform, which is meant to look at
leukemia and T cells in a longitudinal fashion.
So thank you all for your attention.
I'll take any questions if there's time.
Thanks so much, Jeff. We have time for one or two questions.
I have one question, actually. Pretty nice work.
Do you have a sense of... I'm here.
Oh, sure.
It seems that it's driven the cross-presentation mostly on the
NRP, like high cancer cells. Have you tested
NRP1 low cancer cells and see if this is taken up
by APCs? Like the natural APCs might be-
Yeah.
In the cross-presentation.
Critical question, right? Critical question.
Because there's heterogeneity in a tumor.
Here we're using tumor cell lines.
We've done this in early preliminary experiments with primary breast cancer,
but only in vitro, and we get killing.
So there the NRP1 expression is sort of all over the place,
as one might expect. But we do get killing of all the cells
by six hours.
Is there-- Oh, sorry, go ahead.
We haven't tested that in other cell lines.
Well, I'm sort of curious about the
characterization of this internalization processing
cross-presentation
of cellular biology pathway in
non-dendritic cells, right?
Yeah. Me too.
So how well is that biology characterized, and mustn't the
machinery have a huge heterogeneity between patients,
between samples, between individual cancer cells, and why do
cancer cells have that?
Right. Yes. So we've asked this as a teleological question.
What would be the advantage of doing that?
In a paper we published about three or four years ago, we found that if you take
lung cancer cells,
we did this with John Heymach's group, where we had primary human material.
If you take the lung cancer cells and expose them to the same proteases that you
see in the tumor microenvironment in the lung, lots of elastase, proteinase three,
that they will change the repertoire of peptides that are there on the cell
surface. We did that by mass spec on patient material,
in fact, kind of skewing toward peptides derived from proteins
in the tumor microenvironment.
So, we know that this happens in patients with
tumors.
The pathway that we've mapped, we're still not sure about whether that tap is on
an ER, whether it's present in a lysosomal fragment that comes out.
So more work needs to be done there.
It's not as efficient as you see on DCs, where you can get thousands
of peptides in the cell service. Here, you get a few hundred.
But if you have memory cells in circulation, that would be enough to activate
those, because obviously you only need a few peptides.
All right. So thanks again, Jeff. We'll move on to the next presentation.
All right. Up next, we have
Tumor Activated PrimeBody Biologics Platform Enables More Potent
CD47 Targeting and Superior Therapeutic Index in Preclinical Models
by Aaron Springer.
This one?
Hi, thank you for that introduction.
I'm Aaron. Thanks, everyone, for coming.
I'm excited to share with you our work on tumor-activated PrimeBody biologics
platform that enables more potent CD47 targeting and a superior
therapeutic index.
This is my disclosure. So the dirty secret of cancer therapy
is that there are no clean targets, and on-target/on-tumor binding is
accompanied by binding in healthy tissues, and this leads to toxicity and
low drug exposure. And the solution to this, in our mind, is tumor-specific
activation, wherein a masked molecule is systemically delivered,
stays intact in the healthy tissue, but activates in the tumor.
And this is not a new concept. There are several masked T cell engagers and an
ADC that are demonstrating encouraging activity in Phase 1 trials.
However, these programs still exhibit limitations with toxicity,
indicating that the full potential of masking has not yet been achieved.
At Voro, with our PrimeBody platform, we seek to realize this full potential.
This is using highly tunable affinity-based masks.
These allow us to have precise control of on and off rates and
application beyond just antibody CDRs to fusion
proteins, cytokines, or any biologic.
We pair these with our optimized activation linkers that show almost
1,000-fold tumor selectivity.
And the combination of these two allows us to utilize next-generation
therapeutics with no compromise in potency.
Now, every PrimeBody goes through a comprehensive workflow that starts with our
mask library and protease motif library.
But we very rapidly combine the best candidates of these two and
screen ex vivo in human tissues to make sure that we are as clinically
relevant as early as possible in our screening platform.
We then take these best candidates through in vitro and in vivo
screening.Now, the portion of a MASP
molecule that gives specificity is that linker.
You want it to be absolutely intact in the serum and in the periphery, but rapidly
activate in the tumor microenvironment.
And in order to screen our library, what we did is we took a MASP molecule in
schematic here, and we differed just that cleavable linker, which is
that dotted line there.
We took these molecules and we fluorescently labeled them.
And to screen for stability, we took serum from either healthy
donors or donors with cancer. And we, over time, look for loss
of the mask.
And what we found is that for both healthy serum and for serum from cancer
patients, the clinical benchmarks show significant activation, that is
cleavage of that linker over time.
And this is a compartment that you don't want active molecule.
And here we have sort of a slow
leak of these active molecules in circulation.
Compare that to the VORA molecules, which are indistinguishable from non-cleavable
control. And across healthy tissue and four different indications, we've
demonstrated superiority over the clinical benchmarks.
Switching now to activation, we ran a similar assay where we took fresh tumor
tissue from patients. We minimally process it in order to keep the tumor
microenvironment intact. And again, we look for loss of the mask in
our labeled molecules. And what we found is that across seven different indications
and 35 different tissue samples, the clinical benchmark linkers have about a
10 to 12-fold activation over 24 hours.
Compare that to our best VORA linkers that show at least threefold increased
activity over that, across all indications.
This combination of improved tumor microenvironment activation and enhanced
serum stability allows us to achieve between 500 and almost 1,000-fold
tumor selectivity. Compare that to the clinical benchmarks that achieve
only five to 14-fold.
Now we've applied these masks and linker technology to a variety of programs,
including an immunocytokine, an early-stage T-cell engager, and
antibody-drug conjugate. But all of the data that I've shown so far, and all the
data that I'll focus on next, has been with our lead molecule, VORA101, which is
a high-affinity CD47 binder.
Now, CD47 is a clinically validated target.
It is a ubiquitously expressed "don't eat me" signal, which is on the
surface of every cell of your body.
And this ubiquitous expression leads to somewhat of a double-edged sword for
targeting.
On-target binding in the tumor with an active Fc leads to potent tumor cell
killing mediated by macrophages and ADCP.
However, off-tumor binding leads to dose-limiting toxicities,
mostly through anemia and thrombocytopenia, and suffers from a massive tissue sink.
It's this off-tumor binding that has been the Achilles heel for all legacy
CD47 programs and is directly addressed by the PrimeBody
platform, wherein we have no binding in
off-tumor, but maintain on-target binding and tumor efficacy.
In the absence of masking, all legacy CD47 programs have had to
take compromises in their on-target tumor efficacy in order to
address this off-tumor binding toxicity concern.
An example of this, and a rare success for the CD47 field, is
avoracept. Avoracept is a high-affinity
SIRPalpha, which is the ligand for CD47, fused with a null
Fc. And it's that null Fc that's the compromise.
As a single agent, it is safe to administer, but it has no single agent
activity and has to be co-administered with a regimen that includes an active
Fc. In this case, it's trastuzumab in a HER2-positive
gastric cancer population.
Now, in a Phase II trial, the combination of avoracept plus
TRP in the intent to treat population showed an improvement in
ORR and medium duration of response over TRP alone.
And this difference was further amplified in a subset analysis, where about
40% of the improved ORR is attributable to CD47,
highlighting the power of targeting CD47.
However, this is only in the context of an active Fc provided by
trastuzumab in a HER2-positive population.
To put this into context, if we look at the CD47 landscape, we can see
it's very crowded. But if we plot these based off of either their Fc
activity on the x-axis or their CD47 affinity, we
find that there's a pattern that emerges.
And that is that they have all had to take either compromises in their Fc
activity using null or weak formats, or in their
CD47 affinity. And it is only when you take a high-affinity
CD47 binder like avoracept and add it to
an active Fc, in this case trastuzumab, that you get
potent patient responses. This requirement for
both CD47 blockade and Fc activity was also shown
preclinically by the Ravetch lab and our esteemed chairperson, Juan Soriano, in a
triple humanized mouse model where they utilized a CD47 antibody
with an enhanced Fc and demonstrated curative activity with
systemic antitumor activity. However, this was limited to
intratumoral injection, and the systemic dose was too toxic.
Because with masking, we are addressing both the tissue sink and the
toxicity concerns, we are able to, for the first time, use
a high-affinity CD47 binder and an enhanced Fc.
And this really produces the first no compromises CD47
therapeutic and represents a new mechanism of action.
In a single molecule, by targeting CD47, we are not only
blocking the "don't eat me" checkpoint blockade from CD47, but also
using it as a tumor antigen itself for ADCC and ADCP.
And what we found is that in an in vitro phagocytosis model, we got very
potent activity with our non-MASP molecule shown in pink, well in
excess in both magnitude and potency of the clinical controls.
Even with this extreme potency, when we optimize for both MASP and linker,
we are able to push that potency 2,000-fold to the right.Importantly,
this is now below the level of ALX-148, which is avariccept,
which is safe to administer as a monotherapy.
When we cleave our linker, we get full dissociation of our mask
and return to activity of the non-masked active control, as shown in those dotted
lines.
Now, moving in vivo, when we use a double humanized mouse model
and compare head-to-head with equal doses of either migrolimab or our prime
body, migrolimab recapitulates that clinically relevant anemia
where our prime body completely prevents all anemia.
Looking at PK, migrolimab has the expected low serum
levels, which is a result of that massive tissue sink,
whereas prime body has 100-fold increased serum concentration.
Now, despite the fact that the underlying molecule for our prime body, Vor101-S,
is a more potent molecule, these are the same mice,
the same doses. We have completely prevented anemia under these
conditions.
Switching now to efficacy in a Raji xenograft model, which is the
gold standard for migrolimab efficacy.
When we compare head-to-head in an equimolar dose, our non-masked active
control is more potent than migrolimab.
And actually, if you look on the right, when we mask this molecule, we actually
increase efficacy, driving several complete responses.
And we believe that the combination of both enhanced efficacy and
improved safety from the previous slide leads to a much superior
therapeutic index.
So, in conclusion, Vor101 is the first high-affinity
SIRPalpha CD47 binder fused with an
enhanced FC. This is made safe by best-in-class
masking and linker technologies and provides a molecule that we believe
has a wide therapeutic window. Since this is a T cell engager
audience, this can be thought of as T cell engager potency without
any of the toxicity.
Obviously, this can't be done in a vacuum.
We have a very talented team that made this project possible.
And with that, I'd like to take questions.
Thanks so much for this interesting presentation. We have time for questions.
Go ahead, in the middle.
Hi. Nice talk.
I have a question. Do you see any evidence of off-tumor unmasking in
vivo? And if you did see it, which was the first
issue that you started to notice this?
So the question was whether we saw off-tumor unmasking. Yeah.
So we did not see evidence of off-tumor unmasking in this double
humanized mouse model.
The underlying molecule is actually very potent and can't be administered on its
own. And so the phenotype for unmasking is very clear.
And we saw no anemia, which is the primary readout, but also no other
clinical symptoms that would suggest unmasking.
I have one here. Could you speak to the
mouse versus human proteases and specificity for your linker?
Yeah, that's a good question. So,
the mouse versus human proteases.
Sorry. A lot of the masking platforms have actually
optimized their linkers for mice.
They do these screens in mice. They look for hits there.
And we see that there's some translatability, but when we actually use this ex vivo
assay to look at a cleavability of our linkers in mice,
we see that while the benchmarks have more
activity in the mouse than the human, we're the other way around.
We've optimized for human proteases.
So
we're better in humans, but we do still work in mice as well.
And so we do expect that
we get unmasking in the tumor, which is evidenced by our ex vivo,
sorry, our Raji xenograft model.
And the proteases always come from stromal components, never from the tumor
cells?
Yeah. So the proteases come from both the stromal cells, but also the tumor cells.
Mm-hmm.
And so that gives us some advantages when it comes to
tumors
getting resistant, right? They would have to be resistant in the tumor
against all the proteases that we've designed into our linker, but the stromal
cells would also have to become resistant.
They're much less under pressure to do that, and so it's unlikely that we're going
to lose that sort of protease activation.
Great. So there's another question here in the middle.
I'm curious what indications-
Can you get a little closer? It's really soft.
Curious what indications you're going into, and do you pick
indications based on protease profiles?
Yeah, that's a good question. You can imagine that with broad applicability,
both of the platform, but also of CD47, that
we're sort of spoiled for choices.
And so we've down-selected our indications based off of
protease dysregulation, macrophage presence, expression of CD47,
as well as sort of clinical de-risking of the underlying mechanisms.
And we've brought it down to a couple of indications, including
gastric, metastatic colorectal, bladder, breast, non-small
lung cancer, and prostate.
Great. Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much.
All right. We're moving on to the next presentation,
Integrated CD2 Costimulation on CD3 T-cells
Engager Evolve Platform Yields Differentiated and Superior
T-Cell Effector Profile by Emma Stewart.
Thank you.
All right. I'm Emma. I'm a scientist at Evolve Immune.
And thank you for coming here today, and thank you to the organizers for giving me
the opportunity to give this talk.
So today, I'm just going to talk a little bit about the benefits of integrating CD2
costimulation into T-cell engager designs.
My disclosures, obviously, I'm an employee there.
And so when we start to think about T-cell engagers and why we're using them in the
clinic, what we're really trying to do is drive T-cell activation, right?
SoTypically, when you have T cells and recognizing antigen
and antigen-presenting cells, you have this signal one that's coming from your MHC
and your T cell receptor.
But also you're having your signal two, which is coming from a co-stimulatory
signal. And this signal one and signal two is really what drives optimal T
cell activation and mounts an immune response.
This leads to things like cytokine induction, of course, upregulation of activation
models, proliferation of the T cells, and then, of course, with CD8 T cells,
release of cytotoxic granules, so you're able to actually target the cell and kill
it.
And so when we start looking at T cell engagers, we're trying to mimic the
formation of this immunological synapse.
On one hand of the bispecific, using that arm to target the CD3 site
on the T cell, and then, of course, binding to the tumor antigen on the
tumor cell. However, with conventional T cell engager
designs, you're really lacking that signal two, and you're not integrating
co-stimulation, which leads to suboptimal T cell activation.
So we wanted to try and address this question and this problem that we're seeing
at Evolve Immune. And so what we did and have published in a PNAS
paper last year is
using this in vitro screen to try and understand which co-stimulatory ligand
receptor pair best promotes T cell fitness.
So by coating plates with, of course, anti-CD3, as well as a
variety of co-stimulatory ligands, and then adding T cells and tracking them
through multiple rounds of activation,
we can see that if we look at CD2 engagement on T cells,
and its ligand CD58, over time, up to five rounds of
activation, you're seeing increased T cell viability, CD8 T cell expansion,
as well as activation measured by CD25 cytokine release, such
as interferon gamma, as well as granzyme B, which is a cytotoxic
granule.
Another benefit of CD2 over some other co-stimulatory receptors on T
cells is that it's maintained on the T cells in the tumor
microenvironment across T cell subsets.
So this is a summary from seven different single-cell RNA-seq data sets.
And on the left, you can see overall with the T cells, your CD2 is really
highly expressed. Over 80% of the cells have this transcript, whereas with
more commonly studied co-receptors like CD28 and
4-1BB, the expression is much lower.
And then if we go and break that down, across the board, it's pretty low on CD28.
You have some heterogeneous expression in 4-1BB, but again, it's really highly
maintained with CD2.
So this is what we've done at Evolve Immune is sort of integrate, of course, having
the signal one with the anti-CD3, but also using that signal two
co-stimulation
to drive this optimal T cell activation with the aim of creating
more durable anti-tumor responses.
So just to orient everyone to some of the molecules that I'm going to show as
comparisons today, of course, we have the bispecifics on the top that's in the
blue and the yellow versus our Evolve molecules, which is going to be in the green
and the red. This has the CD2 agonist, of
course. And then what's nice about the Evolve platform is we can also play around
with the CD3 affinities. So we have what's called a wild-type CD3 affinity, which
is your more conventional bispecifics as well as an affinity-tuned
molecule that are shown in more cool-toned colors.
So if we take this in vitro model that I'll be showing different iterations of over
and over, where we're coating the plates with biologics and then adding the T
cells. If we do immunophenotyping at a short time point at this 24-hour
incubation period, you can see that the two different Evolve formats in the
green and the red, you see across the board upregulation of activation
markers on CD8 T cells. And then for the purpose of this talk, I'm going to show
everything in CD8 T cells, but we did see similar patterns with the CD4s as well.
So again, if we use this plate-bound model, but this time we're just staining the T
cells with CTV to track proliferation over time, and we pull them at five days.
If you look at representative plots, we're seeing much more proliferation at this
five-day time point in vitro with the affinity-tuned Evolve
molecule compared to the bispecifics.
And if we just quantify this, again, you're seeing a greater percentage of the
cells are proliferating, and you're also seeing more cells at these later rounds of
five, six, seven rounds of proliferation compared to the two bispecifics.
Then if we go and we look at an even later time point, so this is going out 10 to
14 days, replating the cells every two to three days just to maintain their
viability, we can start to look at differentiation into effector
memory cells from this naive
cell state. So in the CD8s here, you can see that in the
affinity-tuned bispecific, which is sort of our weakest stimulation shown in blue,
you're still seeing a pretty substantial naive population.
That's our CD45RA positive, RO negative population at the top left
corner. And you start to lose that over time as nearly all of the cells
enter this effector memory state, with the highest percentage showing
in the affinity-tuned Evolve in green.
And if we count these cells at day 14, two weeks out from the start of the in vitro
culture, while you can see that the proportions of the effector memory and
naive cells are similar, especially in those two middle conditions, the
affinity-tuned Evolve and the wild-type bispecific, you have much more
CD8 T cells in the affinity-tuned Evolve, largely from this benefit in the
proliferation.
And again, if we just look at some Ki67 staining in the green,
you can see you have a larger percentage of the cells positive at this 14-day time
point. Just one more thing I want to note is while you do see a large percentage of
Ki67 positive in the wild-type Evolve, which is our sort of highest
stimulation, you do see a really low cell number at this day 14 because the
cells have started crashing at this point, we think largely due to an
activation-induced cell death.
And so, of course, we are starting to see some of these T cell phenotypes from the
in vitro cultures, but really what we want to understand is how does this
integration of CD2 translate into functionality of our T cell engagers?
And so if we use this urothelial carcinoma cell line in an in vitro
tumor-killing assay, we can start to compare the bispecifics
to the affinity-tuned Evolve. And here we're just showing a variety of different E
to T ratios starting at 1:1 in the darkest color, all the
way down to 1:10 in the lightest. And with the affinity-tuned bispecific
at this low E to T ratio, you really lose potency, and we're only seeing about 3%
killing, which is pretty bad.If you do the wild type
bispecific, you're getting a little bit more of an intermediate phenotype where
you're seeing about 40% tumor cell killing at the highest
concentrations that we tested.
And then the affinity tuned Evolve is a bit more superior, where you're seeing
almost 60% killing at the one to 10 E to T ratios.
This translates as well if we move into an in vivo model.
So this time we're using a lung NCI-H292 tumor model.
And you can see that while the bispecifics do have a moderate phenotype with about
40% tumor growth inhibition,
the affinity tuned Evolve really was the only one that had a significant
decrease in the tumor burden here worth about 60% tumor growth
inhibition at these lower doses that we tested.
And the final piece of data I wanted to share is just looking at some
primary patient samples. So we also have been doing a lot
of this in vitro testing with, of course, healthy human PBMCs, and we wanted to
see if we were able to stimulate patient TILs with our
Evolve molecules and how it compared to bispecifics.
So again, this was that same in vitro plate-bound stimulation assay, just
this time with dissociated tumor cells.
And then we leave them in culture for three to five days and then do
immunophenotyping. And you can see, if you look at the fold change, there
is the greatest increase in that affinity tuned Evolve in the green with activation
markers like CD25 and CD137 or 4-1BB.
You also have the greatest increase in the Ki67 proliferation marker as well.
So just in summary, if you start to look at the affinity tuned bispecific,
which if we're going from left to right, this is really our weakest to our
strongest stimulation of the T cells.
You have pretty limited T cell activation and proliferation, and you do see
limited potency, especially at those low E to T ratios in vitro.
On the other end of the spectrum, you have the wild type Evolve, where the
activation did seem a little bit too strong, actually, and you have an
activation-induced cell death, at least in vitro.
But if we start to think about it as sort of a Goldilocks of T cell stimulation,
we have this wild type bispecific and the affinity tuned Evolve somewhere in the
middle. And the wild type bispecific, it does show activation.
You do see some tumor growth inhibition.
But the affinity tuned Evolve was able to outcompete it in all of the in vitro
assays that we are showing here, as well as the in vivo model for the long.
So you do see the greatest extent of proliferation going out
to 14 days and more durability in the T cell fitness at that time point.
And then, of course, you also see a greater extent of the tumor growth inhibition
in vitro and then in vivo in the models that we showed here today.
And so the big reveal is that this affinity tuned Evolve is our
Evolve-104 molecule. So this is a UlBP256
targeting trispecific T-cell engager
with, of course, the integrated CD2 co-stimulation that's currently in Phase
1 clinical trial for urothelial and squamous carcinomas.
So just as I wrap up, I wanted to thank all of my colleagues at Evolve Immune,
because of course the model development and all of the data generation was a team
effort. And then just highlight a couple of our other presentations here at AACR.
Our trial in progress poster was this morning, and then we have another
poster tomorrow afternoon focused on the CD2 biology, if that's something you're
interested in. All right.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much. We have a couple minutes for questions.
Go ahead there on our right.
Yeah, very good talk. So I-
Hard to hear you. Get in there.
Very good talk. I just wondering, did you check the immune cell
crosstalk? For example, NK cell with T cell or macrophage
with the T cell? Because NK cell express a lot of
CD2. Macrophage express CD2 ligands.
It was kind of hard to hear.
It's really hard to hear. Maybe it was NK cells?
And
No. Sorry. I'll speak louder. So did you check the
immune cells crosstalk between T cell, for example, NK cells?
Because NK cells also expressed CD2, and the macrophage
express CD2 ligand. So what kind of immune cell
crosstalk happen, such as in your TILs?
Oh, are you talking about sort of the ligand for CD2,
CD58, and where that's expressed?
Yeah. Also CD2 in the NK cells, too.
So what's your molecule
effect of this TCR, NK/TCR
interactions?
Sure. So for CD58, I can speak to that a little bit.
It is known, especially for hematologic malignancies, that CD58 will get
downregulated, and that does impact the T cell fitness.
And then I'm not sure what the second part of the question was.
Maybe come to her after face-to-face-
Yeah. You come after.
... because it's really hard to hear through the mic.
So we can go on to the next question. Thanks.
Great talk by the way. Two quick questions. First is that have you seen the...
Because you showed a lot of in vitro data.
Have you seen the less
exhaustion effects in vivo? This is my
first question.
Because most-
In vivo experiments.
Yeah. In vivo. Have you seen the phenotypes that you have seen
in vitro?
Oh, for the E to Ts, you mean? Is that what you...
At the beginning, you repeatedly treated the T cells with the
different ligands, and you see that CD2 is the
best among the rest. Have you seen that in vivo
as well?
Well, we have never tested it in vivo.
It's pretty hard to do a direct comparison between all the ligations and actually
design the molecules. So we've really only done the screening in vitro and then
moved forward with the CD2.
My next question is that you guys seem to have a novel target
entering clinical trials. And how would you differentiate
the contributions of co-stimulations
or the new targets being a good
choice? As in, how do you tell the contributions
when you have novel targets with novel
co-stimulations?
How could I tell the contributions when you see a good clinical data,
thenHow much of that is due to the target, because it's a novel
target, and how much of it is due to the costimulation? I'm just curious.
Oh, just like teasing out the different effects.
Yeah, I guess it's a bit hard to do in a natural model.
In vitro, you can play around with the amount a
little bit more. There is some literature just looking at the impact of
CD2 itself and some of the differences in pathways that it drives as
far as T cell activation. Hopefully, that answers your question a little bit.
But yeah, happy to talk about it more after as well.
Do you have to--
Okay.
I have one short question about the CD2.
We know that the CD2 can improve the efficacy.
Do you think the CD2 also can make the
CRS risk stronger and prolonger?
Yeah, that's a good question. So we have looked at that.
If you're interested in it, there is a lot of that data in the PNAS paper from last
year. But essentially, introducing that affinity
tuning gives you the benefit of having the CD2, as well
as having a little bit of a lower CD3 affinity to really
minimize the CRS, at least in the in vitro preclinical assays.
And then, of course, we'll find out in the clinic in a year or two.
We'll see what happens. Yeah.
Okay. Thanks very much. I think we'll have to move forward. Thank you again.
Okay, so moving on to next presentation.
Preclinical Evaluation and Safety of CVX250 in AML,
a Bispecific T Cell Engager Targeting Cathepsin G-Peptide-HLA
Complex by Dr. Jennifer Hibel.
All right. Thank you for the introduction, and thank you to the organizers for the
opportunity to speak here today. I'm excited to share preclinical
data on CVX250, which is a bispecific T cell
engager targeting a cathepsin G peptide-HLA complex
for the treatment of acute myeloid leukemia and other heme malignancies.
And this work really is the result of a collaboration between Crossbow
Therapeutics and the MD Anderson Cancer Center.
These are my disclosures.
So, as this audience may know, acute myeloid leukemia, or AML,
remains a disease with high unmet medical need.
In the US alone, there are over 20,000 new cases per year, and the
disease has a fairly low five-year survival rate with a particularly
poor prognosis for patients in the relapse refractory disease setting.
Available treatments involve conventional chemotherapy, hypomethylating
agents, and small molecule inhibitors.
And while these treatments have improved overall survival, patients can still
remain largely incurable. And unfortunately,
antibody-based therapies for AML have been largely
impaired or limited due to a lack of tumor-specific surface
targets. And so there's really a need for potent therapies
against novel tumor-selective targets in AML.
And we believe one such target is a peptide from the cathepsin G protein,
which we had a nice preview of a couple of talks ago.
Cathepsin G is a serine protease that's restricted to the myeloid
lineage. It's predominantly found in neutrophils, and it plays
a role in the inflammatory response to pathogens.
However, within AML, it is overexpressed.
Cathepsin G has been shown to be upregulated in primary AML blasts
and overexpressed in leukemic stem cells.
And it's also been shown to be mislocalized to the cytoplasm of these AML
cells, allowing for these cells to present cathepsin G peptides
on HLA molecules.
And the particular peptide that we're interested in, CG1, is a
nine-mer peptide presented on HLA-0201.
HLA-0201 is found in about 40% of the US population,
and the peptide CG1 has been widely identified via mass
spec in patients across different AML subtypes.
And so given its prevalence in AML,
we've developed CVX250, which is a TCR mimetic
bispecific T cell engager that targets the CG1 peptide
presented on HLA-0201 and engages CD3.
We've previously shown that CVX250 mediates potent killing of
leukemic cells in vitro. On the left, I'm showing you in vitro
cytotoxicity data of four different AML cell lines with
different predicted CG1 peptide HLA copy numbers, as shown in
the parentheses for each cell line.
We're looking at the concentration of CVX250 on the x-axis with
percent cytotoxicity on the y-axis.
And for all four cell lines, you can see potent T cell-mediated
killing of these leukemic cells with single-digit picomolar
EC50 values and sub-nanomolar EC90 values across
all these four cell lines.
We've also previously shown that CVX250 mediates potent in vivo
control in an AML CDX model.
Here we use NSG mice that have human PBMCs
introduced to them and have been implanted with the ML2 AML cell
line. When we treat these mice with one of three concentrations of
CVX250, we observe potent tumor control
driven by CVX250, specifically in comparison to the
control T cell engager as shown on the left.
And so we've wanted to build upon these data and to really
determine what the minimum CG1 peptide HLA copy
number was in order for CVX250 to remain effective.
And to do this, we used a panel of U937 cell
lines that have different predicted CG1 peptide HLA copy
numbers on their surface.
These cell lines were developed by our collaborators at MD Anderson and
really span the range of predicted CG1 peptide HLA
copy numbers, ranging from 15 predicted copies per cell all the way
up to almost 8,000 copies per cell.When we
evaluate these cell lines in a cytotoxicity
assay, you can see that we observe comparable levels of
cytotoxicity and EC50 values with cell lines that have
383 copies per cell all the way up to almost 8,000
copies per cell. And we even observe robust killing of the cell
line that has 33 copies per cell, suggesting that
CBX250 is really able to mediate potent killing even at these
low target densities.
So tumor cell heterogeneity is a challenge for many indications,
including AML, particularly within the bone marrow
microenvironment. And so we wanted to evaluate whether or not
CBX250 could mediate bystander killing, which is a recognized
feature of T-cell engagers and is the way in which target-negative cancer
cells can be killed.
The way this works is CBX250-activated T-cells are
able to potently kill target-positive cells.
When this happens, these activated T-cells can upregulate various surface
markers like FAS ligand and LFA-1 and can
secrete cytokines like interferon gamma and TNF alpha.
These cytokines can act on nearby target-negative cancer cells,
inducing the upregulation of FAS and ICAM-1.
And through the interactions on the surface of these cells with the target-negative
cancer cells and the activated T-cells, the activated T-cells are able
to kill these target-negative cancer cells.
And so in order to determine if CBX250 could mediate bystander
killing, we co-cultured a mixture of target-positive cancer
cells and target-negative cancer cells with donor T-cells and evaluated
the cytotoxicity of both of these cell lines in vitro.
The ratio of target-positive to target-negative cells ranged from
100% target positive all the way down to 0% target
positive.
On the left, I'm showing you the cytotoxicity data from the target-positive
cells, which is consistent with what we've seen before.
We see nice dose-dependent cytotoxicity of these target-positive
cells driven by CBX250.
And on the right, when we look at the cytotoxicity of the target-negative cells,
we actually observe
nice dose-dependent increases in cytotoxicity of these target-negative
cells only when the target-positive cells are present,
suggesting that CBX250 is able to mediate bystander killing.
We also wanted to build upon our safety data and to determine whether or not
CBX250 could induce any cytokine release in healthy donor whole
blood. To do this, we evaluated eight different cytokines
following incubation of soluble CBX250 across five
concentrations, and we found no meaningful cytokine
induction of CBX250, specifically in
comparison to our two positive controls shown in red and orange.
To further evaluate the safety of our molecule, we wanted to determine whether or
not platelets are activated by CBX250.
So although platelets likely don't express CG1 peptide, they can
express high levels of class I HLA and therefore may be
targets for potential cross-reactivity against CBX250.
So to evaluate this, we cultured platelets with
CBX250 and then evaluated platelet activation using a flow
cytometry-based readout, specifically looking at P-selectin
expression, which is a marker for platelet activation.
In the middle, I'm showing you the results of the positive control, CRP.
We observe a really nice dose-dependent increase in P-selectin
expression as we increase CRP concentration.
Whereas on the right, when we evaluate P-selectin expression following
CBX250 incubation, we don't observe any increases in
P-selectin expression, suggesting that platelets are not
activated by CBX250.
We also wanted to evaluate the specificity of our molecule by screening its
binding across a library of over 6,500 human proteins.
This is a platform developed by Retrogenix and is widely utilized to
evaluate off-target binding interactions.
So we evaluated CBX250 using this platform at a high
concentration, and we found no significant specific
interactions detected with any of the human proteins evaluated, with
the exception of two, one of which was CD3, which is, of course, one
of the primary targets of CBX250, and the other was
FcGR2A.
So we believe that this interaction between CBX250 and
FcGR2A likely occurs through the FC domain of our
molecule, which contains the clinically validated silencing
mutation Lala KA. And while this mutation greatly
reduces binding to the FC gamma receptors, it doesn't completely
eliminate it. And we believe that this interaction was observed likely due
to the high concentrations of CBX250 tested using this
platform.
And so finally, we wanted to evaluate the pharmacology of our molecule by
assessing serum pharmacokinetics in naive male monkeys following a
single ascending dose. The PK profile for IV
administration on the left and subcutaneous administration on the
right were consistent with IgG-like molecules with a
half-life ranging from seven to 14 days for IV
administration and eight to 12 days for subcutaneous
administration.
So overall, we've shown that CBX250 has potent in
vitro killing capabilities. It's able to target
cell lines with very low target copy numbers, as low as
33 copies per cell, and is capable of inducing bystander killing.
We've shown that CBX250 displays a strong safety profile with limited
cytokine release in whole blood and no impact on platelet activation,
and that it's highly specific to its targets with no significant off-target
interactions found after screening over 6,500 human
proteins. And lastly, that CBX250 has an
IgG-like half-life and PK profile with minimal immunogenicity
risks in data that I didn't have time to share with you today.And so taken
together, these data support the clinical development of CBX 250 and a
phase one trial is currently underway.
So thank you for your attention, and I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thanks so much for a clear presentation.
We have time for a couple questions.
I have one question. Very nice.
So some AMLs actually apparently express FCR2A.
Have you guys looked whether that engagement of like even if it's minimal of the
molecule, could modulate some of the activity?
Could you repeat that? Sorry.
So FCR2A can be expressed on AML.
Mm.
So the question is that even if it's a minimal engagement of the FC
portion, do you think that can potentially contribute to the activity or
aggregate the activity in any way?
Yeah. So,
I would say we're pretty confident that it's actually not going to be engaging
FCGR2A,
just based on some follow-up octet studies that we've done.
But it does sound like, I guess from what you're saying, that it could also be
beneficial should that be the case, if I'm understanding your question
correctly.
Something that could be monitored.
Yes, for sure. Something that can definitely be monitored.
I'm curious about
sort of uniformity of antigen expression.
So with Tebentafusp that we use with uveal melanoma,
the HMB45, the GP100 is so
highly and uniformly expressed in those tumors, and that's thought to be
part of the mechanism of efficacy.
And so
I'm a little bit curious about whether the mechanism of tumor cell
killing is different in vivo than in vitro, and if you won't pick up the
bystander killing in real patients.
Yeah. So that's something we'll certainly have to wait and see.
I think we're very encouraged by at least the preclinical data showing
that we're able to target those low copy number cells and able to induce
bystander killing. I think unfortunately we won't have the answer to
that until we see the clinical efficacy, but I think
overall our preclinical data suggests that hopefully we'll be able to
mediate some of those effects.
There's a question over here on our right.
I have two questions.
Just one. We have time for one.
Okay.
So prioritize.
Right. So, in the clinical trial,
do you need to screen the patients based on the CG1
presence?
So, we're planning on doing that retrospectively.
Oh.
So right now we're just enrolling patients that have HLA-0201
positivity, and then retrospectively we'll look for-
I see
... the CG1,
and cathepsin D expression.
So as long as they're
0201 positive, they're enrolled, right?
Yes.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay. Thanks for a great presentation.
All right.
Last presentation, Gastrointestinal Tumor Associated
Target: A First-in-Class Therapeutic Monoclonal Antibody by Dr.
Jenny Go.
Hi.
Good afternoon.
So thank you very much for this opportunity to be part of such a
great session. I do believe this is the last talk, so
hopefully I can keep you interested till the end.
My name is Jenny Go, and I'm here on behalf of my
team called Resers Therapeutics.
We are a small biotech startup located in
Seoul, South Korea. And our main mission is to develop
novel solutions for cancers, especially those that do not
respond well to current immunotherapy.
And so today I will present our early preclinical work on a
first-in-class monoclonal antibody targeting a membrane
protein highly expressed in gastrointestinal cancers.
This is my disclosure information.
Okay, so let's get started with a very well-known medical unmet need.
Immunotherapy has greatly improved... Oh, is it?
Sorry, not
going on.
Use the clicker.
Ah, okay.
So
immunotherapy has greatly improved survival outcomes in
many cancers. However, while it is a miracle drug
for those who respond, the percentage of patients who
do respond is still quite low, especially in tumors such as
MSS-CRC and pancreatic cancer, which show virtually no
response to immune checkpoint blockade.
And this is largely due to the fact that these cancers have an
immune excluded TME, where effector T cells
fail to infiltrate the tumor, and NK cells are largely
dysfunctional.
And this results in response rates for such cancers
around the 20% mark,
indicating checkpoint inhibition alone is not sufficient
because the TME is not permissive to immune activity.
And today I will be introducing to you a monoclonal
antibody that could possibly be the key to solving this
problem.
So we decided to focus on a target called
TM4SF5. And what is TM4SF5? It is a
tetraspanin transmembrane protein overexpressed in
gastrointestinal cancers such as hepatocellular
carcinoma, colorectal cancer, and esophageal cancer.
But the important point is not only is it highly expressed in these
tumors, but it also plays a functional role in shaping the
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment,
eventually leading to cancer progression and poor
prognosis overall.
And mechanistically, TM4SF5 contributes to such
tumor progression and immune evasion through signaling
interactions.So it acts as an anchor in a
microdomain we call term here.
TM4SF5 interacts with the IL-6 receptor to
enhance its STAT3 signaling, eventually
modulating T cell related cytokines and chemokines, and
also with SLAMF7 to induce its internalization and
degradation, leading to evasion of NK cell
recognition.
This makes TM4SF5 not just an expression marker,
but also a functional driver of the immunosuppressive TME.
Now, this biology is reflected in real
patient data as well.
When we stratify the patient data in public databases into
high and low TM4SF5 expression groups,
overall survival was found to be worse by about
twofold in the high expression group for both
HCC and CRC.
And through our collaboration with the National Cancer Center in Singapore,
we ran some RNA sequencing of HCC patient
samples, and we found that TM4SF5 expression
showed a positive correlation with immunosuppressive
genes and a negative correlation with those related
to immune activation.
And altogether, we were able to find that
high TM4SF5 expression can
identify with tumors that are potentially difficult to treat
with IO, pointing us in the direction of a
biomarker-driven therapeutic strategy.
Now, by this point, you might be wondering, if this is such a
great target, why has it not been developed before?
Why are we first in class? Well, the bottleneck is not
because the target itself is not attractive, but the
difficulty of effectively targeting this transmembrane
protein in its native conformation with the conventional methods
for antibody development. So to overcome this
challenge, we embedded TM4SF5 into a virus-like
lipoparticle in order to mimic its transmembrane-like
structure and use this to produce an extensive
antibody library. And so we were able to come up
with a monoclonal antibody that selectively recognizes the
conformational epitope of TM4SF5 in its
native structure.
And we
found a candidate antibody with excellent binding affinity and
further optimized it, and we call this
RCT1213.
Now, RCT1213 binds the conformational epitope,
spanning both extracellular loops of
TM4SF5. So I mentioned that it's a tetraspan, and so it
has two loops, EC1 and EC2. It
is very important that we are able to mask the entirety
of the loops because we found that only when
it binds across both of the loops can the antibody
disrupt the integrity of the microdomain in such a way that it
creates steric hindrance and weaken the immunosuppressive
effects that I outlined before.
As a result, we saw that IL-C receptor signaling and
downstream STAT3 activation were inhibited, and
disruption of SLAMF7 interactions restored
NK cell recognition on the tumor.
And we were able to see that RCT1213
effectively shifted the TME towards a more immune
permissive state
than before.
So we performed a series of characterization studies for
RCT1213.
We did a shotgun mutagenesis epitope mapping
of RCT1213 to confirm, yes,
that it binds to both the EC1 and
EC2 loops, and we saw excellent
binding specificity
in the cell lines that we tested. And also
in a biodistribution analysis of a tumor model, we saw that
RCT1213 targeted the tumor with minimal
off-target accumulation in normal organs.
And as a result of this targeting ability, we saw the
elicited immune responses that I mentioned.
We saw increased CD8 positive T cell population
in the tumor and also decreased Treg
proportions.
We also checked the suppression of immunosuppressive
cytokines and angiogenic factors, as well as
increase of immune activating factors such as
CXCL10.
Now the key question is whether
all of this translates into actual tumor control.
So we tested this in several in vivo models,
and we have two of them for you here today.
In the HCC model on the left and the MSS CRC model on
the right, we saw that RCT1213 achieved
significant tumor growth inhibition
of about 80%
at its max. This was comparable to a
leading first-line regimen, atezolizumab and bevacizumab
for HCC, and significantly better than
pembrolizumab in MSS CRC, which is known to
be largely not working in such
environment.
And what's particularly interesting is not only that we
see standalone efficacy, but in combination
settingsRCT1213 demonstrated clear synergy
with ICIs, with the triple combination of
RCT1213, atezolizumab, and bevacizumab
achieving complete response in all of our samples.
So collectively, we see that we're able to enhance
responsiveness to checkpoint inhibition in cancers that
are known to be difficult to treat with immunotherapy.
And we further validate this in a CRC PDX model
derived from a patient tumor sample,
known to have poor response to ICIs.
And RCT1213 demonstrated dose-dependent
tumor suppression in this case. And while not all
samples responded, as you can see in the waterfall plot on the
right, those that did showed substantial TGI
of about 60%.
And given we have not fully optimized the effective dose
in a patient-derived model, and that this
is a T cell deficient model, there is definitely room for
improvement,
which we are currently
conducting at this moment.
Nevertheless, we believe this data supports meaningful activity of
RCT1213 even in ICI refractory settings,
and studies are ongoing to continue
development in this direction.
Now to conclude, we are developing a highly selective
antibody with an immune-mediated MOA that helps to
reshape the immunosuppressive TME, also
enabling strong synergy with immune checkpoint blockade.
And we are pursuing a biomarker-driven strategy
using TM4SF5 expression for patient selection.
And with all this, we would assume the natural next step would be
to develop it into bispecific antibodies in order to
best leverage its excellent combination effect with the
ICIs.
And overall, while this is not a final product yet, I
believe this is a strong proof of concept for a
promising target, and we warmly welcome any discussions for
potential collaborations as we move forward.
Thank you very much, and I'll be happy to take any questions.
Thanks so much for yet another interesting presentation in this session.
We have time for a couple questions.
I was curious, so when you were looking at the changes in the
immune microenvironment with this antibody that is
affecting signaling that has secondary immunologic
consequences, you looked at CD8 T cells and
Tregs, but in GI cancers in particular, the
myeloid cell compartment is really key.
Macrophages, the suppressive macrophages, or
inflammatory macrophages. Did you happen to study the macrophages?
Because that could be a second node that's going to have to be targeted for GI
cancers.
Oh, that's a very good point. And yes, we have done studies
in the macrophages. The reason we didn't bring the data here today is
because we weren't able to confirm it in all of our models.
We did see in the HCC model
that we see a shift towards
the more
immunoactive state of
macrophages.
But it was not
very significant in all of our other models.
So it is a-
Something that you're paying attention to.
It is something we are interested in and we're trying to
investigate.
Sounds good. Any other thoughts from the
viewership here?
Okay. Thanks so much.
Thank you very much.
Well, I just want to say one thing
for a summary. I think the
variety of approaches that we saw in this session, I think was
really impressive in terms
of conceptual advances and
actionability on some
of these conceptual advances.
Decreasing the affinity of an antibody to increase specificity for the tumor
cells.
The concept of antibodies against peptide MHC complexes
used in different ways. Mast antibodies that are improved
for
exposure of the antibody binding portion of the molecule in
the tumor microenvironment.
Switching up the T cell side with alternative
costimulatory
ligands or receptors, so with CD2 as the example here, but there are others
being pursued in the field.
The novel mechanism of antibody-mediated
cross-presentation in cancer cells
as a strategy to now give new peptides and then
transfer T cells. That's a
particularly novel strategy. And now here, the last one, it's a free
antibody, not yet
coupled or used as a bispecific, or we haven't talked about
once you have an antibody against a tumor target, there's also the CAR T
strategy that can be pursued. But the idea that there are still yet to
be discovered free antibodies that could have immunomodulatory
effects through cancer cell signaling.
So I was impressed by the spectrum of different
approaches that people are taking, and obviously, still
more to do in the future. And thanks for attending the
session.